quissac tonnes profit du répit que les
pluies et le temps plus frais lui ont
donné dans sa lutte contre les feux de
forêt il est à la tête d'une quinzaine
de pompiers ruraux tous volontaires
because of you il y a une semaine sont
téléavertisseur l'alerté comme toujours
il va la station avec ses camarades il
sort les véhicules et ils seront là où
le feu menace les habitations
une braise emportée par le vent a mis le
feu à la végétation ce qu'il faut faire
c'est se rendre à la tête de l' incendie
et le contenir pour qu'il ne s'approche
pas de la propriété
on voit que ça a été juste c'est ce que
font les pompiers ruraux à travers tout
le sud est de l'australie
des fois c'est impossible depuis la mi
novembre près de 1600 maisons ont été
détruites
mais plus de dix mille ont été sauvés
cela implique un travail épuisant de
brûler les broussailles en périphérie
lincendie pour le priver de combustible
qui lui permettrait de se propager
la chaleur est intenable si vous voulez
perdre du poids du tice ce régime idéal
tribune fait le reste ce sont les avions
ou les hélicoptères qui s'en charge et
l'australie n'ont n'a pas assez
des centaines de pompiers spécialistes
des feux de forêt sont venus du canada
des états unis de nouvelle zélande
le shérif neuf chaînes on retrouve non
seulement il y à échange de
connaissances et de techniques mais
surtout ils prennent la relève après 12
semaines épuisantes
la fatigue est un gros problème pour moi
ce sont les pompiers eux-mêmes qui ont
construit la station et le gouvernement
paie seulement pour les véhicules et le
carburant
pourquoi faire tout ça gratuitement qui
ne se pose même pas la question
une façon de rendre service à la
communauté
à 68 ans semi retraité il consacre une
journée par semaine et un week-end par
ci par là au service en temps normal
c'est comme ça en australie et il est
reproché aux experts pour nous c'est
normal et on ne s'attend pas à être pays
dans l'expectative est à illfurth jean
michel leprince dans les nouvelles
galles du sud